yeah they didn't call real world a
reality show reality TV became a thing
after Survivor
let's do that when I know no real world
was a reality show they just didn't call
it that but that would be the first
reality show yes correct they literally
called it real world right but they
didn't call it oh we gotta fire above
these guys dude
you ever met this guy oh I'm the dumb
you can't argue sure
[Music]
all right look dude what you guys we got
some
you might be like what's with the
background I I don't recognize it we
spicy coming in we're not announcing it
yet but you'll you'll see in the next
two weeks dude I mean we're not even
close to done but it's super tasty we're
not but we got we got this going on and
then next week Eric's not gonna be here
and then the next week shooting a movie
forget it
next week forget it dude in two weeks we
got something You're Gonna Wanna set
your calendars do it I don't know what
they that is but uh first week of
November
25th November all right look Nick either
way second second November November 2nd
we got to talk next yeah
um
we got something that we are unveiling
and uh and that's it speaking of
unveiling I will be in Savannah Georgia
on Saturday and Raleigh uh on uh Friday
the day before that and then I'm gonna
be in Boston I got a the second show at
the Wang uh some tickets left and uh and
that's what's up crystalia.com speaking
of unveiling I'm gay oh no I'm not I'm
gonna wait two weeks oh God that was the
big announcement now we're [ __ ] God
damn it I had the date wrong anyways he
was supposed to come out on the third
boom so there yeah I'm in Salt Lake City
this week uh Calgary next week Thursday
Friday and then after that I'm in San
Antonio Houston get you some uh speaking
of the unveiling Nick you uh you shaved
the beard oh yeah oh that's what's
different
but no but I thought I was like why does
Nick seem nicer yeah now he looks 41. I
love it yeah he looked way younger yeah
I don't like it I think I have a soft
jaw but honestly honestly I like his jaw
that's kind of what every guy thinks
though you know you gotta uh I don't
mean everybody thinks you have a soft
jaw I mean every guy thinks that they
have a soft jaw
or did you see me shrink it's a new set
yeah all right we're working through the
wrinkles all right some things pop off I
want to get too big
my [ __ ] know what happens I look like a
goat yeah there's a ghost in here you
know who that is
we gotta talk about Finance
and then the ghost doesn't show up and
we're like it would be crazy there's
like a nanny can we don't know and he's
been into like a control board just yeah
[ __ ] with it shutting down cameras
we're like it's a ghost
uh Nick why'd you shave though if you
hated your yeah uh so I went to uh
bravocon this weekend oh yeah the shirt
yeah everyone's so clean cut there
though yeah you had to be no I bought
this off a staffer so I could get in
wherever I wanted and skip the lines and
the third day they caught me and kicked
me out so I shaved changed and went back
you got to be kidding me no I blocked
the whole thing this guy's insane
yeah winter house uh do I see me get
kicked out
does he physically harm you no okay
let's see it yeah [ __ ]
is it are you on the uh
are you on a GoPro here uh yeah GoPro I
was I was just walking around with it
because I had the staff shirt on so I
thought it was like a new thing they
have a criminal cam now yeah hey real
quick the guy with the the Fufu drink on
the her's nails painted or oh yeah they
are I think it might be a larger woman
yeah you have Bravo wait no on the right
on the right no no there's a woman it's
not the guys that's hilarious it's like
an optical illusion yeah no I'm not
talking about that handsome woman I'm
talking about the guy in the room no
it's not his hand that's not his hand
holding it just looks like it's oh I see
okay hit it from the T I heard
[Music]
are you
yes
he's following you right now yeah I
don't have any he asked me for right is
this is this all face yeah that's all
that stuff's fake what yeah
and this was just so you'd have to wait
in line it and to yeah I was doing a
bunch of singing so you can meet your
favorite cast members I was taking
people from back of the lines and
ushering with the frontal lines what
group of ladies paid me 50 bucks
quite the hustle
and now he starts yelling for security
but they didn't know who he was talking
about sure
you look nervous
walking slow they just always say walk
don't don't run oh wait look at this
thing his forehead is sweating as hell
uh yeah and you're all by yourself yeah
I don't [ __ ] around with it
um
did you see any of your favorite cast
members oh yeah uh Kate Chastain Queen
of the sea captain Lee Captain Jason the
whole group yeah two captains Rachel
watches below decades all right I've
heard about it yeah yeah I used to work
for Bravo and we did a show and I had to
I had to binge watch like all whatever
seasons of Real Housewives of Spokane
Real Housewives of Utah all this [ __ ]
what how many do they have it's so a lot
now it's like 10. real housewives of
Atlanta Real Housewives of Orange County
was the original now right uh Nashville
Dallas New Jersey Atlanta Dallas and now
they have one called real girlfriends of
Paris
they're in Paris they should have wow oh
I Used to Love Don't Be Tardy yeah there
you go Potomac that was the one I have
to binge watching it was a doozy
Vanderpump is the original OC's
fantastic all those dudes that one dudes
and the guys and girls that Vanderpump
would come to my show yeah damn they
have 12. and I don't care Vanderpump is
in the family of Housewives yeah isn't
that it's under the housewives umbrella
was a housewife of one of them
they were all really cool to me man
these are subsidiary shows like what are
the other wow I I did a show that uh uh
that show with Andy Cohen and one of the
Orange County girls on there and she was
white girl wasted yeah
my yeah Andy Cohen uh that whatever his
job is the recap stuff that he does
impossible job that's my uh nightmare
that's the worst job I think there's
there's a question no there's a worse
job I'm Loving Hip-Hop because you like
no no because I want to Stir It Up yeah
the face you don't even have to watch
the shows the favorite thing is to watch
the wrap-up shows when all the people
are there and you're just going like
this so why'd you slap uh Charlie and
they're like I just slept you know he
was like it seems like that's the light
of the tape but you're not yeah but it's
not but you but it's not something
you're interested in to me what he's
interested [ __ ]
yeah load me up dude yeah I'd rather be
like I'd rather be like load me up dude
[ __ ] I'd rather be a bukaki boy yeah
dude let me take [ __ ] this is getting
barbells to the no barbells to the face
[Laughter]
does he want barbells but Andy Cohen's
easy compared to uh Love and Hip Hop
because there's always a fight loving
hip-hop's the toughest gig so I'm saying
they're fighting on there I don't know
I've never seen it you remember about
you know you ever seen Bad Girls Club oh
right you told me about that we watched
it on this on here Love and Hip Hop
Autos I love all that I like cardi B
came Loving Hip-Hop that's she got her
first pop really yeah she was a
character it's a crazy Survivor started
this all that show Survivor the first
like reality TV was it survivor yeah no
was Survivor before remember those shows
that like love and hip or uh was it
Flavor of Love and Rock of Love well no
the real first one is uh Sharon you know
what's that osbornes Osbournes no that
that's no no no Survivor was first I
don't know real world I think real world
what reviver was Network and it popped
it off yeah but but it was but the real
but Survivor was the first time you
heard a reality show no real world yeah
no but it's real bro things right yes
yeah they didn't call real world a
reality show reality TV became a thing
after Survivor
no real world was a reality show they
just didn't call it that but that would
be the first reality show yes correct
they literally called it real world
right but they didn't call it
oh we gotta fire both these guys
wait these two are feeling themselves
they look at the set and they go like
this yeah stuff's gonna be different see
what happens we see what happens when
you get a new office manager now these
guys are like
they're all gonna come in they're all
gonna be buffed dude Mark's gonna be
training them all
right they're all [ __ ] these guys and
then for some reason we're gonna be over
there
let's switch the camera why am I looking
up stuff on Google
and Google that [ __ ] I'm pulling [ __ ] up
five things I'm like what am I doing
Nick goes can you give me a Diet Coke
yeah right away
uh reality television emerges to sing
genre in early 1990s with shows such as
the real world in the 90s and then the
success of the series Survivor American
Idol not really big brother
no but America that's not a reality show
yeah okay actually I see it Rick and I
was a competition you know what it's
like though but you know what's like the
version now you know what it's like
when you say when did social media start
everyone thinks Myspace Friendster was
first friends but nobody [ __ ] says
Friendster because after Myspace that's
what kicked it off this is what the
Survivor did reality TV oh the real
world the real world did for Survivor
yes real world was the French translator
yes that's what I'm saying it was the
first one yeah yeah so me and China
right yeah so basically yeah wait wait
hold up
back then dude that nobody was calling
[ __ ] nobody was calling Real World
reality TV when Chris is wrong we're
gonna do like this
[ __ ] off man [ __ ] I'm pissed already
can we start doing a scoreboards and
that kind of stuff I don't I didn't like
I don't reality TV makes me sad bro does
it mean Flavor of Love It love was
fantastic it all makes me sad though you
walk out dude nobody turns off reality
TV and goes ah they turn off your TV and
then they go about their day and then
[ __ ] a few hours in they're like oh
because you're watching if you don't
drive it [ __ ] [ __ ] you up that's
like that show couples therapy on
Showtime it was like heavy dude my girl
wanted to watch him like if you want to
fight I'd rather fight in person
it was real I don't I think I think all
reality TV is a little bit of a producer
it is yeah you know like if like if
ultimate Fighter's not if this was like
reality TV Nick would be like you know
being like hey remember yeah no they'll
do that stuff it's real stuff like
ultimate Fighter's not scripting any
faster well you guys are dealing with
but that's but literally you're like
there's a fight yeah no hold on I have
to make a fight because I actually have
to the fight's the smallest footage on
the show the show is the guys in the
house it's real world and you mix the
real world with fighting but the
majority like the drama in the show's in
the house but they would like like if I
asked for food it'd come like two days
later if I ask for alcohol to come 30
seconds later because they knew that
would create oh
yeah so easy to [ __ ] drink at night
just think of any time you add I want a
glass somebody to come live at your
place like like imagine living with
someone you don't even know even someone
you like sort of know like even we know
each other right I don't know if I want
to live with you guys oh no I know oh
man Eric's burping in the other room
yeah he's [ __ ] with his feet up like
whatever he does God oh yeah on a poop
thing yeah no
that's why you're not sure Eric what
this is me Eric what is this
all the time
[Laughter]
there's just Tupperware in the
refrigerator yeah what is this dude
imagine living with Nick he's just up
all out
but his dumb dogs would be all over the
place and he's not giving him attention
I can't wait you I can't believe you
wear black you have all those dogs
you know what only one of my dog sheds
oh they're all hybrid oh well yeah so
and and and uh he's a lot of of black so
can't see it camouflage doggy guys let's
take a break take a break you guys know
what hello fresh is or do you live under
a rock we're talking about that home
delivery food yeah you get fat look with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
it's so easy skip trips to the grocery
stores and count on hello fresh to make
your home cooking easy fun and
affordable yeah but if you don't like
saving money that's fine but hellofresh
is 72 cheaper than dining at a
restaurant it's even cheaper than going
the freaking grocery store that's money
back in your pocket money back in your
pocket it's so easy whatever you're on
whatever diet you're on we got you
covered they have over 50 different
weekly options you can skip weeks if you
need to change your delivery date update
your whatever you want and they have a
hellofresh app you can do it all right
there all right they sent me some food
they sent me the meals my girl can't get
enough of it now we're never eating out
I'm kind of disappointed whatever it's
still delicious go to hellofresh.com
king16 use the code King 16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts that is
hellofresh.com King 16 use the code King
16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts all right King one six
don't write out 16 you know what I mean
I gotcha yeah it's just like you'd say
king one six that's the code hellofresh
America's number one meal kit fellas
have you ever used those dick enhancers
at the gas station like
rhino3000. oh I'm always scared dude I
could see the moon and I was rock hard
and I thought I was gonna have a heart
attack yeah they're not that good right
it's not healthy yeah I took one once
and then I woke up in a whole different
state yeah yeah yeah it's not good I was
in Wyoming I was I had never been to
Wyoming I'll never do it again that's
why I trust Joy mode yep it's here to
save the day all right whether you're
happy or unhappy with your performance
in the sack why not perform better hey
guys I care about your wieners out there
Joy mode sexual performance boosters
like a pre-workout but for sex that's
right man Joy mode is all natural it's
backed by science we got you covered man
all right after taking the sexual
performance booster blood levels just
climbing it's just crazy people people
go like to add links to better their
mental health and well-being dude what
about when you want to lay horizontal
you know I mean what about when you want
to make that mattress go eat on you need
performance what about your wiener
exactly don't forget about your wiener
want to spice it up in the bedroom and
boost your sexual performance and do it
naturally without the nasty prescription
drugs cool here's an offer for the king
this thing and the wing and the sing
audience go to usejoymode.com Kats or
enter k a t s at checkout for twins time
for your first order that's
usejoymode.com Kats for 20 off your
order thanks Joy mode wiener thank you
what do you got Nick
this wasn't even planned but this guy
have a strong chin too what's up boys
this is Paxton from Dallas Texas sorry
for the Glitchy video [ __ ] company
got me working on this stupid ass
[ __ ] Android I got a little debate
clubs
reality TV shows people versus Duck
Dynasty I know Theo's not on anymore so
this is probably a piss alley but
[ __ ] him all right boys
this guy's really aggressive seeing all
that [ __ ] uh this guy Customs a lot he's
aggressive what's up [ __ ] faces love the
[ __ ] show my stupid job would just
dumbass Android
he's so aggressive the two shows he
named I don't watch I know reality TV I
used to like I didn't even know but
Chris had a good point I'd watch I'm
like I'm not learning [ __ ] here I'm just
watching these dummies act done I was
about it's such a waste of time anytime
you have some like what's the three of
us on the right redneck white people in
their element
oh that's good oh you like that yeah
that's Chris Eric and Brendan yeah yeah
that's the three of us Chris on the left
you know which one I am yep you're the
one with the hair you're skinnier you're
the skinnier one well I'm the one with
the beard and you're like this I'm on
the far right yeah yeah yeah that's my
tattoos yeah that's my face yeah yeah
the cutoff shirt clearly doing most of
the work look I'm looking I was like
[Laughter]
yeah that's you I what I I was Chris is
the comic relief on the left clearly
um so hold on cut off overall yeah well
I think that's kind of a cool outfit
that's what I was saying I don't love
that the shorts but you know I wore
overalls as a kid I would wear overalls
but wait hold on so I don't know Swamp
People they got canceled the Duck
Dynasty got canceled right because like
I said something racist yeah I mean dude
but awesome they should call it the
racism hour oh yeah I'm just saying like
you're in your room you know you don't
there's not a lot of ethnic people even
around you you have your own ideas and
you're comfortable and you're just gonna
be like wow yeah I mean if that dude it
was delivering the package yes he shaved
and became an Amazon delivery guy yeah
but also look at them even mad at it
beards of course they use the n-word
well yeah but the Beards say the ending
look at everything the American flag on
the American flag on his head it's not
even a hat well I like that yeah no I'm
not saying it's better I like the guys
on the right they have a gator farm I've
never seen either of the shows I'm not
into that I could get those guys on the
right [ __ ] laughing those guys on the
left I can't get them laughing no that's
a tough crowd on the left they go what
what real sir what that's your crowd in
Fort Wayne Indiana on the left it was
tough fellas yeah
on the right I got they go this guy's
crazy crazy what the what the ones on
the left that's like chin is on the far
right
the guys on the right after the show
you're getting some bears and going
gator hunting the guys on the left go
like this we don't take too kindly
joking like that and you're like what I
was talking about I was making jokes
about Ikea and they say we get furniture
from there boy boy what the [ __ ] can I
make fun of I wouldn't I wouldn't even
try not around these parts what yeah
they were not even close to a [ __ ]
Ikea Nick I feel like you'd tuned into
Duck Dynasty or like swamp boys or I
never watched either that he went to
[ __ ] Duck Dynasty con with a fake
beard
it's called a KKK right yeah yeah it's
like a Santa Claus beard yeah
but it was the Swamp People was the
first show on History Channel so it
basically ruined the History Channel
from being and history education from
being history yeah yeah that's the thing
about these [ __ ] channels is
hilarious they all become the same thing
dude there's no history on History
Channel no there's no music on MTV
there's no comedy on Comedy Central
there's no weather on the Weather
Channel there's no learning on the
learning there's no news
there's no news on the news well
fake news yeah that's what I'm saying
but it's not real to your point on the
Weather Channel it's like Ice Road
Truckers and all that kind of stuff
going on in The Weather Channel The
Learning Channel is like just just any
little people little people doing little
people yeah yeah yeah okay you know kids
you mean like midgets well you can't say
that but little people yeah okay editor
no I think you can say I think you could
say honestly if I was a little person
I'd rather be called the the in a [ __ ]
than a little person don't call me a
little or dwarf or whatever yeah one of
my women Lord of the Rings yeah I know I
don't like that either it's too when you
call it somebody a dwarf a town it
sounds too science fiction
call me a wizard instead of like you
know
how do we feel about troll how do we
feel about troll yeah
oh my God
check out this [ __ ] wizard
hey wizard
in my broom you shall not pass us me my
friend Greg man he's a troll oh [ __ ]
yeah offensive
what was that show with the dude from he
he oh man what was that oh my God what
does it do this real skinny dude and he
had a uh no it was like a comedy show
but he was like yeah I was dating a
troll and then it was like a real troll
oh not Tom Green no no it wasn't a
screenshot it's a scripted show I don't
know I don't know the name of that guy
he was like the skinny guy but he's a
weird skinny guy and a bunch of no it
was like this weird abstract show I wish
I could remember the name of it he's
really dating a troll yeah you know that
was the joke Rod man doing was it that
one yeah it's like a real troll I think
it was on Comedy Central but it was like
so funny is it possibly called man
seeking woman
I don't know if this is
ah yeah let me see the guy the star
yeah yeah that's way great
well make it yeah yeah I mean this
[ __ ] take God dick no you can't say
no he's trying on things I wasn't ready
yes Jay what's his face yeah this is it
man seeking woman wow dude okay Nick
that was a good pull you know what dude
I think oh that's the guy from uh uh
She's Out of My League there it is right
there yeah that was his girl he's like
dating a real troll you know and every
oh and another one another funny one
they had on there was like his sister
somebody's like dating like Hitler's
still alive and he's in like uh you know
he's like
it was really funny abstract show I got
back from my hotel there was him right
there yeah this is That's supposed to be
Hillary with that mustache that's funny
and he's like you know they make yeah
our contract was on that oh I love Eric
such a good dude yeah that was one of
those like I think there was a yeah oh
sorry shout out to that show you know
what movie I I came home to it was just
I left the the TV on in my hotel I come
back and I was like I had my food there
it was like one in the morning I'm like
I've seen this [ __ ] thing it was from
the 80s and I was like man why did I
know this so well it was my favorite
movie as a kid that's where I have CT it
was my favorite movie was a kid I was
like I've seen this I knew everything
coming up
remember
that was terrible well I mean I was a
kid me too now it's like I thought it
was terrible then wow well you're also
40 then [ __ ] this just as a little kid
yeah dude get on Urban myths Urban myths
movie trailer have you seen this bro
just look at this movie trailer oh there
we go go ahead have you seen this yet hi
can I help you I'm looking for day so
Bob Dylan great Carrie Grant Dr Leary
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that looks like they made that for like
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's just crazy though he's a
great actor I love that guy oh yeah he's
great he was actually good in uh
Schindler's List yeah English Patient
um red dragon
he he got he got Typecast as like the
Family Guy a villain yeah
it's hard for him not to play anything
but that it's weird too because he's
such a Charming handsome dude you know
yeah but his brother Joe finds his uh he
he had a moment there does he does he
have an actual uh Cliff lip
I gotta say this I want to say on the
podcast too it's like I just got back
from skank Fest and it was a blast
really I was gonna I wanna because so I
know I don't really know anything about
it's so funny I I went to uh follow uh
uh Luis Gomez right and uh because his
he commented on my thing something nice
about how I had like my son was cute I
was like oh that's [ __ ] Lewis so I
followed him and uh and I looked and
this was October 16th I followed him and
the only reason why I noticed because I
I had a DM from him after I started
following me he's like hey if you want
this is back in like
March he was like you should do skank
Fest this year uh it's from October 14th
October 16th and I followed him on
October 16th
[Laughter]
how weird is that but I gotta I'm
telling you right now
it was a blast it's a great comic hang
and all of the people that are there
that they're they are true podcast
comedy fans yeah bless you it's like
it's like Comic-Con or something like
that you know so I've heard it's dope
it's a really good time and I want to
just give a shout out to all the people
that came there were a lot of great fans
there and it's like I said it's also a
great like hell yeah
better than say Montreal I'm just saying
because that's why I'm saying where do
you get a hangout as a comment that's
what I mean without having that sort of
feeling like there's some hierarchy and
press yeah well that's the thing about
that is like I was thinking about this
like when it comes to Comedy festivals
like they're always trying to get the
the comedy festivals are usually trying
to get the biggest names right like and
skank Fest has this
I I know nothing about it but I I just
saw the videos that he was posting and
like they have this um
it's always good to be the guy who like
it's not as big as Montreal right of
course but yeah that's good though yeah
it's good because it's like I was
talking to um but man Jim Norton was
there because Hollywood
but I bet but I bet uh Chris Rock or
something right I don't
but that's good though that's good skank
Fest doesn't want that and no they want
the comments what's my favorite comic so
I'm not saying but like skank Fest wants
that whole like
here we are [ __ ] like these
guys exactly yeah
and it's also started by the comics
right I know but what I'm saying though
is like I would also dig if like someone
like Chris Rock was like hey I don't
want to deal with this other thing I
want to go be you know and then oh of
course that's what I'm saying but again
you don't want it to turn into like two
but anyways
I just want to give them a shout out
Lewis big J all the people that were a
part of it that made it shows there too
yeah yeah that's and it was a good
hangover was there it's great coming all
those people were there Jake he did his
special there BJ did yeah oh yeah yeah
so it was just like how do you start a
festival you know you just go hey we're
gonna go here you put it out on the
internet like Hey we're gonna go we're
gonna be here and then the people just
come in they buy their passes and it was
it was jam-packed they had fights they
had like yeah to me is crazy it was so
funny it was like was it was it getting
hurt no they didn't make it they were
yeah it was just yeah crazy it's not
commission so I'm sure it's just [ __ ]
around just messing around sounds like a
good time and they had it at this
location in downtown Las Vegas they took
over this sort of like three level area
that had theaters and stuff and there
was like a a center area where they had
to fight everybody was lined up it was
jam-packed but here's the thing all the
shows were great yeah it was like a
comic no that it doesn't matter so Oh
you mean vibes okay I'm saying because
we in Montreal man you know how to it's
summer time right now they're sensitive
and all this kind of stuff no these are
comedy fans yeah so every show is good
every show like those festivals some of
the rooms I had a one o'clock I had a
one o'clock in the afternoon show and
you would be like one o'clock
dope everybody because they're there all
day they want this that sounds crazy
you know I'm not saying it just sounds
that sounds like like I think I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna get these
guys and we'll figure it out around me
yeah we'll figure it out I mean skank
fast coming to you 2023 so did they do
it different places every year yeah yeah
even though I think they should still I
think they should do whatever it sounds
like the place today they should do it
in Vegas especially because dude Vegas
unless it's like
I mean Vegas doesn't really I don't know
maybe it has a scene but like the scene
in Vegas is like this theater [ __ ]
this guy's coming Jay Leto yeah exactly
right so girl has residency there though
yeah no they have Wise Guys there now
this was in downtown
that's where the local downtown's where
you want to be yeah downtown you want to
be locals go you know that's where Wise
Guys is downtown yeah yeah and which I
will be at November 18th and 19th Wise
Guys coming to Vegas
all right cool let's see what uh
Scooby-Doo Girl Wants
that looks pretty
good hey guys what's up my name is Roxy
and I have a debate club for you sorry
guys I'm extremely nervous you guys and
I listen to you guys all the time
um so I'm kind of shaky
um so over the weekend uh James Corden
was found from a New York restaurant and
he profusely apologized to the owner to
let him back uh he was being extremely
rude to the waiters and the staff
members there
and so after apologizing the owner said
he could go back he unbanned him so my
Debate Club is would you unban him or
would you keep him banned and make him
learn his lesson uh gang gang
look I'm not I I don't I I have a I
don't know James Corden I I I've seen
him he seems like a guy who behind
closed doors is a an [ __ ] that's what
he seems like he seems like a guy that
other British people would go like ah
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I mean
like they just I I guarantee no British
kids like him how oh that stuffed [ __ ]
the second and it's like is he fat or
not it's like make up your mind it's
mental so like it's like so uh so he's
he look at this they but okay so I
looked into this because I talked about
it on congratulations in my podcast
I I this is the kind of thing though
that it's dude he was a dick kind of to
a waiter and now it's all over TMZ and
[ __ ] well but why would you he was rough
and then he goes if you don't give uh me
and my wife free drinks and all the
other drinks around the house I'd hate
to leave a Yelp review for you of course
dick dick and so that guy was like well
before you do it I'm gonna go out and
before you get me and ruin my business
right but my whole point is this social
media [ __ ] [ __ ] just handle it with
each other dude this whole I'm because
now this guy Keith McNally or whatever
[ __ ] knows if he goes on it's gonna
make headlines it's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
walk up to be like yo [ __ ] leave
it leave a yoga group that's a dick move
you know if you do that I'm gonna ban
yeah or you can be cool Devil's Advocate
over here thank you
um what recourse does regular people
have of somebody that they perceive as
with this sort of influence and and you
know a Yelp review from him is gonna go
viral and [ __ ] the guy's business so
like they said okay here's how we're
gonna combat this we're gonna combat
this like repo now like hey be nice to
people because it's Gonna Get out no no
I I it's kind of like but by the way I'm
with you on like let's say when people
don't tip and then and then they're like
they're they're they're posting that on
the internet right crystalia doesn't tip
right look at this receipt right okay I
don't like that but at the same time hey
Tiff no I understand that but like it's
the only recourse they have I get it but
like these are these two instances if
you read these two instances one of them
is like all right
you [ __ ] up the order yeah he could
have been nice the other one what if he
had a dude what if I mean you don't know
what the [ __ ] person's going through
but twice still Chris once I forgive
twice right I understand but the other
one isn't as bad if you don't have the
first one but you do have the first one
and that's what the guy's going off of
yeah I understand but but my point is
one of them to me he was a big dick the
other one he wasn't he was like kind of
like at the same place yes yeah
which action came first the smaller one
and then the big one like he was like
giving the guy a chance big one then
smaller one okay here's the thing man I
mean I I was in Vegas one time and uh
one of the owners of The Palms those
Brothers the Maloofs Maloof Brothers I
like to play craps I'm at a craps table
one of them loose Brothers walks up and
my goodness man he was losing okay and
then he's like what the [ __ ] and he was
like I don't want to look at her he's
talking about one of the people that
works there she looks like her out of
the way you know yes and the guy was
like does she look like a troll though
no you're right it doesn't come on yeah
somebody's life yeah and what I'm saying
is like he was clearly exercising his
wife his power and his influence and he
was being a dick without any recourse
nowadays if somebody would have been
filming that and they put it out it's
like hey [ __ ] you don't be like that
yeah
right I mean I guess I guess it's the
good and bad you don't like the [ __ ] I
guess I guess no I guess actually what
I'm getting at is sorry I guess actually
what I'm getting at is
he was a dick really nice moment this
guy calls the dude out for being a dick
okay so that's shitty and then
and then this whole people saying [ __ ]
James Corden yes that's that's not like
that that's you're like the mob into
town yeah it's like they got to deal
with it yeah that's what I'm trying to
do the two-man is uh this is a do you
know who I am situation yeah right like
do you know who I am I should be treated
extra special no and that's what that is
mean to her then I'm pissed I know these
mean to her it's it's the good and bad
of social media it's like a double-edged
sword and it sucks yeah I think it's
that little boozy said I hear you I'm
with you I think it sucks fellas can we
take another little break we're having
so much fun on the new set UFC 280 is
here UFC 280 is here get closer to the
octagon with DraftKings sports book the
official sports betting partner of UFC
right now new customers can bet five
dollars on UFC 280 and get check this
out to a hundred dollars in free bets if
your fighter wins okay I'll tell who's
gonna make money Eric knows the thing or
two about fighting now I'm sure
night flashbacks he knows his thing so
if you want to bet do it with draftking
Sportsbook all right and you want even
more action say less you can also double
your winnings on a same game parlay
combine multiple bets like which fighter
will win how long the fight will last
you what matchups Charles Oliveira there
you go getting it done under five rounds
against mock Chev he's a dog and he
could do it all right so there's not
like Sean right here Sean Brady get it
done via submission under the three
rounds all right everyone who wants to
boost their winnings plays a UFC 280
same game parlay today download
draftking Sportsbook app right now use
promo code Kats throw down five dollars
on UFC 280 and get 200 in free bets if
your fighter wins that's code kts this
Saturday remember it's 11 A.M Pacific
start time for the main car remember
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply C show notes for details little
boozy had a good thing on social media
he's like it's only made things worse
for everybody yeah he's like if you
think about it social media has not done
Society any good he was rap first
getting killed more than often the hate
is more than often we hate each other
you know it's dividing everybody he's
like social media has done way worse
than it's done good what I'm saying is
like like I think unless you got to
promote data if you can't Salt Lake City
if you can't say oh by the way Seattle
I'm actually my Seattle tickets are
almost gone Chrisley and that's where
social media helps yeah there we go look
at you you're taking advantage of it
right now somebody filmed them being
mean to me then I'm gonna put that on
but you know what I mean [ __ ] wizard
we put it out every week
but I know what you were saying in your
head everybody does
um anyways social media whatever so yeah
look let them back unban them he was
being that's what he did yeah yeah no I
know she's saying should he have oh yeah
I think you should it's weird to hold
that resentment against someone that
only hurts you
James corden's feeling like this every
place he goes now he's going to be like
hello yeah I know I know but you know
what a Daft calm yeah
because table being like let's do table
carry okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no she but also he should Oh you mean
you now you're on the spotlight you got
to be nice you have all the money in the
world be [ __ ] cool dude but also
don't have tits like that right right
well now I have the same shirt on and
said whatever I think it's more about
the shirts [ __ ] about the shirt [ __ ]
well that's what he was eating that's
why he was angry you know he looked
angry on the right is he cold or is he
happy to see me I have that jacket go
back go back go back yeah
I have that jacket and I asked you what
size it was because I want to buy it
boy he was thick yeah who knows man I
don't know him he's probably a nice guy
who [ __ ] he's nice I don't judge
people oh you did yeah I remember after
I finished my set he comes over to me
and he whispers he's like that was that
was the best
comedy I've ever seen on the show and I
was like you say that all the time only
two other times that's funny he's great
at that yeah I mean he's not doing it
anymore this is last year but I remember
George Lopez I did George Lopez when he
had that late night show I did his set
and uh actually funny with that because
I I did um you know those jaw the job of
segment producer they'll come around and
they'll be like I want to check out your
set for the [ __ ] late night you know
people know this or not uh it's not a
job it's it's not a job it's like it's
like the movie Hitch with Will Smith
it's like that's not a job people have I
don't like these movies in Hollywood of
like these made up jobs like hitch he
helps people this doesn't exist don't
make what was the it's called a life
coach no yeah but it but it's not though
it's it's this guy's good it's just
making them look cool my point is my
point is
um this segment producer will say hello
comedian I work for Jimmy Kimmel I want
to come see your five-minute Act and see
if it's suitable for our audiences you
go on stage as the 15-year vet comedian
[ __ ]
do your best five minutes you murder and
then they say what if you try and you're
just like you're not a comic oh bro
okay right so
so I was going to do Lopez tonight was
what it was called and the the segment
producer was like we want you to do
Lopez tonight why don't you why don't
you come do uh five minutes we're gonna
come see your your ex so the guy comes I
do my my five minutes I think would be
good I Crush
um and he says
um
why don't you uh not do the first part
because I don't know if that's going to
be good for our audience it wasn't for
any reason then he said uh I don't know
if the George Lopez audience will like
that
just men meaning I don't know if they'll
think it's funny yeah so I go
okay I won't do that part and he says
great you're hired
I do the show and I do that part of
course because I I do this yeah they're
gonna like it yes I I crushed and then
and then Lopez came up to me everybody
was like that was the best set we've
ever had and I remember how [ __ ] good
that felt dude like I was a young comic
you know what I mean like and like you
know I don't know who had done the show
before but like man it felt so [ __ ]
good can you the late night wait if you
do something
you didn't see him there I probably did
but I was just like you know I was like
okay you know like well to the guy's
credit the guy from James Corden that
that guy
he was saying to me like oh no do that
like I had some edgy stuff and he was
like nah dude it's gonna be a guess so
my [ __ ] wasn't even edgy
look at you look so Armenian were you
nervous for this you look like Sam right
here no if I was you know I was probably
nervous I but but once you get the first
life it was such a great crowd wow
that's cool I look cool yeah Chris
tucked around there too what okay so he
said you know
cool
uh yeah who did it cuter that's the pole
yeah it was long huh Jesus Christ I wish
you would put in a ponytail no it
doesn't look good with me yeah then it's
just all for you yeah that's what I want
yeah
yeah and In fairness that's what he
wants all right let's see what's going
on he looks like a parrot you know what
I mean
hahaha
Brendan knows his Birds wow yeah what's
up guys I got a debate club for you
today so would you rather be attacked by
a bear on the side of a mountain like in
that viral video
or would you rather be sued for a
billion dollars like Alex Jones
both are pretty bad
um yeah I'd have to do the bear attack
because I don't have that much money
yeah but
um I love you guys come to helium and
Philly sometime I'll buy tickets for all
of you
um gang gang buzz buzz soar and
wow all the same note um
um yeah this this attack is absolutely
insane got the smaller barely right yeah
but that bear was just fine
well that's what they said they said he
ran into a banana beer in the tub that
was the little one maybe he wasn't
playing no but the mama bear you don't
want that Mama Bear
he turns around the mama bears just like
this
because the mama bear was teaching this
one go get him yeah yeah yeah teach him
how to kill [ __ ] well first of all I'll
take the billion dollars because you
don't have a billion dollars Alice Jones
doesn't have I know I know yeah but
they're gonna Garner your wages for the
rest of yours exactly he's gonna be
living you're going to be paying that
maybe you can't pay a billion but you
can be paying I wonder what it is like
if you're make if you make 20 million in
a year connotation okay yeah I actually
had dinner he has to live yes recently
yeah oh yeah he has to live though right
you can't so like in the state of Texas
they sued he lost the child they
whatever he's got sued for let's say 55
million the limitation he has to pay is
5 million so he can't pay more than 5
million that's the limitation the state
of Texas a year
oh so so it they so on the news it says
55 million but really paying five he's
he's on the hook for five the whole time
no life for life well for life he pays
one-time fees out in Connecticut we
don't know where this happened right I
don't I don't know their limitation whoa
oh so he's gonna maybe may he could be
fine in Texas he's fine I don't know I
understand yeah well I don't know is
that is that right because this guy
doesn't make up things
it's what right we looked it up oh yeah
no we fact checked them yeah but this is
Connecticut's different I don't know
connect's not Texas I don't know what
their limitations we tried looking up
and now you have to fact check
everything he said oh I'm hungry you're
like oh yeah
it's not even dinner you gotta go out
you gotta check his pulse I think you
wait a minute that was two and a half
hours ago I don't know
yeah I don't know how much you're not
paying but yeah imagine you have to like
live in like a two-bedroom apartment you
made a hundred million dollars and it
all goes away they give you a little
stipend to live yeah well right right
like it was just like I would just be
like I'm not gonna work anymore
who'd you rather be Alex Jones or Kanye
West right now oh one they're both voted
off the island but Alex's Island they
they he's their mascot yeah but same
with Kanye dude Kanye is buying parlor
you see that he wants to buy the Apple
yeah
um I don't know man I'm a Kanye fan too
it's just like I'll see this stuff I'm
like God damn don't find it but they'll
find a way to stop that too though what
parlor yeah they'll find a way to like
do like the the all that's gonna do is
trigger some sort of legislation about
social media that's all that's gonna do
what is or what's gonna do if he let's
say he buys Parts yeah and now he's
gonna be able to go on parlor and be
like the Jews then that's when people
are going to be like well now we got to
make laws about stuff yeah that's what
the limitations yeah I don't know what I
don't understand is what why do you want
to like
it's like when I say this on my podcast
as well but like when you like
these dudes who say oh I can't say the
n-word uh Free Speech though it's like I
should be able to you know you shouldn't
you you restrict words then you start
restricting you know and it's like but
why do you why do you want to say it
that bad and by the way that's people
that don't understand of course the
first American what it really means yeah
because that's not what it means it's
just like you can't like they say you
can't call fire in the [ __ ] in a place
and it causes harm right right you know
anyway right the point is people don't
understand that Free Speech means people
have free speech to also not life right
but anyways we're getting way too
serious yeah yeah
um I'd rather be you're making a lot let
that answer the question I'm making too
many points no no I'm not saying to
America today I enjoy Point guy because
you know why because you started off
with because okay I talk about my
podcast and then you give us a rant yeah
but I enjoy it oh it's too much dude
that's assault dude are you uh Alex
Jones or Kanye which one would you
rather be Kanye
I don't I don't wanna oh a billion
dollars yeah Kanye has a billion yeah
Alex does for now all right
I saw an article today that he's talking
they're talking about he's his people
close to him he's blowing through money
how about how about Chase Bank said
[Applause]
they should have given him his money in
like like in pennies yeah yeah you know
what I mean oh here you go here's your
here's your 100 million dollars in dimes
Get Loud back up the truck yeah yeah I
see I thought the White lives matter and
that stuff he did at that I was like all
right he should be all right but then
when he did the Jew thing I'm like now
you [ __ ] up no you know what I mess
with the juice man you [ __ ] there's a
point where I thought like maybe he's
just playing with us playing with the
media trying to make it think but that's
what I thought too because people are
talking about them and it's like that's
what he's known for he can't even stop
him either because even if you take him
off Instagram he just goes someplace and
starts to talk yeah and everybody's
filming him and it's going on there yeah
he's still going out but yeah I think
that I was like like what with the juice
not even just that
when I saw the Jew thing the George
Floyd thing I thought it was like what
are you doing he said Fentanyl and it
wasn't like he wasn't even on his neck
like that and it's like dude man there's
videos we see it it's like what are you
talking about but uh he was definitely
on his neck and then he was also on
fentanyl but all all this is he's he's
mentally ill to be clear he's mentally
ill he needs help it's a little bit of
my problem with this distract me I'm so
sorry is this a little problem with this
is
sometimes do things everyone's like he's
a genius another time like he's he's out
of his mind it's like well so when is he
genius onesie out of his mind when he's
having his manic episode you don't like
him and then if he does something you
like he's a genius and then you talk
about the Jews though you're pregnant no
hell no but that and then also some of
the media Outlets they never list them
as being a genius it's always always
having they only cover it when he's
having this manic episode it's not gonna
be like
genius Kanye West talks negatively about
Jews it's like you could say you could
say you could say Empire Mogul Kanye
West having a moment
I guess he [ __ ] up did you think man
of course it's awful it's awful it's
awful well I think all of this he's
[ __ ] up [ __ ] up now the other stuff
you had been okay it's not good no no I
was like ah all right that's crazy yeah
yeah well you knew he was gonna push it
with the Jew thing though I'm like Oh my
and then he's doubling down on it and
then the George Floyd thing I'm like
this isn't good yeah I don't know what's
gonna happen because at certain point at
a certain point Chris has Yeezys on
there's a certain point that people are
like you yeah yeah yeah then they'd go
oh man I can't yeah yeah yeah now yeah
cause even with Alex Jones
um even with Alex Jones there's got to
be a point where even his staunch
followers is there any moment where they
go ah why'd you say that well yeah but I
think families I think that what happens
is but I think there's a difference
between there's a difference between
Kanye West and George Floyd or sorry
George Floyd uh Alex Jones Alex Jones
stands for something it whether whether
you agree with it or not he thinks he
stands for and so do his followers Kanye
West is an artist so I think that I
think that I I disagree I think as a
business as of late he's come across
like he stands for something too what
this whole the whole thing about
supporting Trump and the white lives
matter but he flip-flops too much Alex
Jones has been about one thing he's been
about freedom of speech you know for
[ __ ] years and conspiracy no it is
and conspiracy theories stuff that's
like right but that's free speech so
when he God I'm making too many I'm
sorry dude I'm making too many I want to
be funny it's a new set it's the new set
I know about it
last time you [ __ ] yourself let's go
come on we gotta we got it dude
now this is up my alley uh yeah yeah I
know that dude I remember going
someplace all right you know and I got
and I got there I died
I like how this big kid it was like a 40
it was like a 45 minute drive and I got
there and I'm just about to get out the
car and I was like oh is this a fart you
know what I mean yeah
it was like it was like oh you know and
that was like and I still wasn't sure so
I did it
um
how much would I pay to see your face
but it was like this I had to go in
yeah
wait Chris is going in through the front
and then I pulled out and I was like oh
no I [ __ ] [ __ ] myself and then now
I'm dealing with this I got [ __ ] on my
finger and you can't get rid of that
smell human [ __ ] on your fingers but
here's the thing I'm 40 minutes in I
can't turn around and go home yo you
were in the car so I went inside to the
bathroom you know what I mean I took off
my pants you should go you should have
took off my underwear and I used the
underwear to like finish Yeah clean up
yes yes and I cleaned up
that's the gangster move that's the
gangster that car ride I've been there
that car ride that was like but the
whole time I was like oh I'm feeling a
little but this I felt you know
occasional thing I cracked off a couple
ones and it was fine but there's a
certain part wait there's a certain fart
that you know oh something's coming it's
like a pre like a like an earthquake
like a yeah
uh imagine driving by and you see Eric
in the parking lot
in the parking lot okay so a mom with
the kid in the [ __ ] she's awesome
I'm going like this and I look over
how long ago the kid's like I do that
um no listen dude that's so that's
horrible dude yeah it was horrible it's
just horrible if I was 10
dude where are we going I was
yeah it was like yeah yeah of course it
was you know sometimes when you have
like certain kinds of farts it leads to
you know diarrhea is coming because your
body being like we're trying to get this
out so it's like
oh my God
and it's a mess it's just a mess but but
it was like it was a squeaker that I
thought I stopped it that's what I'm
saying so it was like I went yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I thought I got it yeah I
was like a jizz like a little rope yeah
I thought I got it oh my God I got it I
was like I didn't get it you did bukaki
on your [ __ ] butt dude the levee's
broke
oh he didn't want to talk about the last
time he [ __ ] himself because it was
[ __ ] I can't I was trying I can't
realize time [ __ ] myself I played
Russian I have I play Russian you ever
fought you ever been in a fight never a
fighter
locked up yo there's been there's been
never been punched there's been like two
examples no Justin Kish and you all
Romero yeah there's been two but in
general caught each other oh [ __ ] oh
remember when Larry Holmes after he
fought Tyson vomited oh well that's just
extremely thrown up he was just walking
across the thing after the fight
yeah he probably shouldn't have drank oh
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh that's disgusting
that's that's Turtle ooze because he's
built like a ninja turtle oh no oh man
the other person smells that that's
actually a good technique yup tap tap
you know how you know how they're real
close this kid's is worse because this
is actual [ __ ] on the mat right [ __ ] I
just [ __ ] yeah look at that that was
a chick she squeezed it out of her but
she didn't tap yeah
and here comes Eric Griffin on his way
to dinner
here comes the Griffin what is it oh
this girl was in a hot tub and then she
like just and then the diary was like
everybody jumped out of the tub no hell
no hell no
no you were there
by girl you mean I didn't jump out right
away I was just like dude I mean I told
this story on stage once a few weeks ago
but man I went to New York once and I
got there all early in a jet lag I woke
up early and I woke up at like 6 a.m I
never wake up at 6am and I was like I'm
gonna go [ __ ] stroll the streets in
New York I'm gonna [ __ ] just be a New
York guy right I take a few steps I get
a [ __ ] uh this is it oh that's it
yeah let's get her look at her face
sheer tear yeah this is it
everyone's like what the [ __ ] Becky this
is another one the one I saw was like a
black girl did it oh this is
she's like oh no
she doesn't tried farting in the tub she
knows right now she goes oh [ __ ] my
stomach
Is that real
I like the way she stood up
she's mortified with herself right now
because in her mind she's been like oh
God I'm gonna be you know shitty Sharon
for the rest of my life you gotta own it
oh yeah yeah you know
I would have just sat in it like yeah
sorry
turn on the jet yeah you have a hot tub
Chris uh yeah
okay
don't let Eric
let me do it
I'm [ __ ] in Christmas hot tub
was this gentleman what Eric what's this
nothing why is it brown all right
all right guys I got a debate club for
you movie star versus Rockstar see by
the mic behind me trying to do the rock
star thing that mind I would go movie
star all day the shelf life of an artist
so short I'm
33.70 in this business
but uh Curious to hear what your
thoughts are gang gang buzz buzz okay
first of all being an actor for a long
time is different from being a movie
star people are not movie stars for a
long time it's only a handful of people
some people Tom Cruise is a movie star
for his entire career Leonardo DiCaprio
yeah yeah Johnny Depp yeah but if you're
talking about so if you want to be one
of those guys then yeah all right but
but I think I would rather be like a
movie star then like a rock star who has
to now do you know 700 shows a year I
wouldn't be a rock star there would be
many things I would rather be than a
rock star I do not want to be a rockstar
I would not like that at all yeah you'd
rather be a movie star Yeah Yeah you
sort of you're not working you're kind
of a rock star you're on the road the
thing about the Rockstar thing that I
don't like is I don't give a [ __ ] about
singing
yeah because I had to be well versed in
all of it yeah he had a really his
childhood was like you know they were
just like all right don't raise me fast
I'll let you go
so not myself bill came in it was like
do it him him and Matt had to harmonize
and they were crying yeah
there's 525 600
.
and you need to do it again
my brother What About Love up it's like
that scene from uh Step Brothers yeah
I've never seen that oh you haven't
watched that brother
he's like in the whole family you're not
even seeing it right 300 or less you're
not even doing it I'll take it from here
uh no but but it's like you don't sing
but it's equivalent to doing comedy and
being like whatever that is yeah but but
the being silly thing is that rock stars
are too serious dude that's not funny
though but also but the Rocks already on
the road all the time okay yeah
50 years before it's not corny like roll
you're corny Bro you've been killing for
10 years you're corny 50 60 years really
doing this [ __ ] you're not courting
anymore because they're your Legends I
disagree and that's the end of the
conversation no no I disagree I think
that you're corny when you're like if
your song is corny and again it has a
shelf life like if you're these guys I
Wanna Sex You Up that's not corny yeah
you keep you can't do that anymore yeah
yeah yeah like every morning when I wake
up is that him yeah yeah yeah that one
every morning when I wake up in him I'm
talking Nobody Knows the next one
boyfriend boyfriends bad check it out
baby don't say a word right I don't
think that's a gay version Smash Mouth
that guy's a disaster now he was
hammered that one yeah he showed him so
that part because you know his song I'm
Gonna feel where he just keeps saying
and it don't stop coming and it don't
stop coming and it don't stop in the
edit and it's like [ __ ] 10 minutes
have you seen it it makes me laugh bro
he's not doing it shows up at this thing
there's barely anybody there I know he's
like nine beers deep I know so you're
all we're all saying we'd rather be like
there's movie star because you don't
have to travel all the time on the road
movie stars oh dude that's so funny it
keeps cutting back to that and that's
all it is for [ __ ] however long it's
like an hour they don't stop coming for
10 hours
it has three million views
oh because you send that to your friends
you sit next to your friends and you go
like shout out to the great late Brodie
Stevens oh he had this great video of
him jump roping for two minutes and what
you do you send it to people and you go
what you have to wait for the end oh man
and there's nobody get through it
it's just that's hilarious just him
doing the whole thing this is him Jim
broke me the whole time and then he puts
the jump rope down and that's it and
then everybody writes you back like this
two minutes away
oh man that was great stuff nobody was
funny like that dude
that guy didn't send it but he said he's
trying to be a rock star so I asked him
for his music do we want to hear yeah I
love it we'll tell him if he should get
in the accident okay
yeah it's his if he signed off on it
gifted youngsters written by no feelings
no feelings
smoking okay oh where is that what city
Toronto cannot escape this journey man
the greatest getting flagged for the
late hit steps I retrace this all the
way back to May 15 1989 the Gloria
[Music]
two jackets with the same jacket two
different colors same jacket I got a
green one got a gray one
yeah
[Music]
it's not bad
it's not bad and he set up the whole
video with like it's like not only is
the same jacket but it's the same shot
one shot like go to one take to that
City now could you tell a difference
that I changed my jacket the only thing
change what's the jacket
and now we now we show that version you
know but we have an update from uh
what's up Eric the nose guy he just sent
in a video I actually haven't seen it
yet that's my God yeah oh hell yeah he
looks good she ain't starting to look
like word up man he looks good I know he
looks like Nick
yeah hey guys it's Eric I just want to
give you an update after the nose
surgeries it is all complete I feel like
I have fully recovered I am back at work
full time and I also just wanted to send
my gratitude out again of how you guys
have treated me in this studio
I really appreciate it you're a thick
boy more to me than you'll ever know
thank you for helping me through the
rough time of my life and gang gang buzz
buzz
God looks phenomenal yeah I mean still
breathe's better than me what's that he
breathes better me I guarantee it yeah
even with the ones you know you know
it's like it's one of those this is one
of these life-changing moments and I
hope his like from it's all up from here
bro yeah man it looks you look so much
better so much better so much out there
Eric won him 400 on cats after dark oh
yeah now catch after dark on YouTube no
we're we're gonna Rebrand a new after
show I think all right check out
unlisted afternoon
but yeah I love this guy yeah he looks
dope in that thick boy that's great
that's great gotta get him man he'll be
an intern with George yeah it was just
like a bunch of Misfits here yeah yeah
broke face guy [ __ ] broke face guy
former fat guy dude that knows when he
first done that video that juicy nose
fresh out the surgery I think it was
juice all right guys yeah we did it
Seattle it's selling out you better
hurry up chrislea.com [ __ ] Savant
just comes out Thursday right yes
Savannah Georgia every Thursday Raleigh
[ __ ] Boston that second show we fill
it up dude it's the casino come check me
out with this [ __ ] date
Colusa Casino I'm coming to you well my
dates can I get my little dates out but
like I don't like
um
two shows two jackets
shout out to that dude what's his name
make sure you put him in there you know
the youngsters gifted youngsters gifted
youngsters uh I'll be wearing two
different jackets on stage in Salt Lake
City this Thursday Friday Saturday we
got a fight companion Saturday at 11 A.M
Pacific Time on thick boy YouTube next
week Calgary Thursday sold out we had a
show Friday at the rooftop downtown
Calgary then after that I'm in San
Antonio Houston get your tickets thick
boy.com also thick nectar stop calling
it next time
you can get it go to thickboy.com batch
two guess the awards on the side stay
connected nectar dude wait till you're
done to do all the [ __ ] I'm sorry I had
to you you think I can control my body
this guy [ __ ] himself on the way to
dinner
love you guys
[Music]
how many times I gotta make this song
wait I get the gist I just probably have
to slow it down and hit it like this
[Music]
thing in the way let's go
Legendary Trio what you mean you know
it's the king and the sting and the wing